- Next up is Chris,
knowing what you know today,
what advice would you
have given yourself when
you were first starting?
Different planning, or other ideas?
- That's a great question, Chris.
I think I would have,
number one, you know,
I would have, absolutely,
my idea would have focused
on what does the audience need.
What does the customer need?
What is, and where do we find them?
And then, the other great
advice I'd give myself
is surround yourself with great people.
And people who challenge you,
but people who are on
the same moon mission.
As you are.
People with the same
vision, the same ambition,
the people who want to kind
of, literally fly to the moon.
And if you do that, you're
probably going to be
hugely successful, and it
might not be necessarily
on your first venture,
but you'll come across,
as you evolve your idea,
huge success.
And in the context of this in confidence,
you know, be really happy
if you do fail fast,
learn quick, and build a great business.
- This is a hard one
for me, because I'm so
happy and grateful for where I am now
that everything that led up to this moment
has shaped who I am.
And so if I change something in the past,
would I still be here?
That's the internal battle
I have when I get asked
this question.
But I would probably, if I had to answer,
I would say just believe
sooner and harder.
Finding believe, and going all in on it
has had such a tremendous
impact on my life,
and on my business.
And it's been a newer
phenomenon in my life.
I mean, maybe three, four, five
years, something like that.
If I discovered it sooner
and went in on it faster
and was bolder and had
more confidence in it,
now we'd probably be, you know,
hopefully further ahead
than where I am at now,
but um, at the same time I'm
really grateful for my spot.
- I think I'd say, be a
responsible risk taker.
I remember one job where I
was working really early on
in my career for a big, safe company.
And I resigned to go to a crazy startup,
that did become a really
successful company.
But I went back for the
weekend and talked to my
mum and dad, who were alive at the time,
and I said to my mum,
"I'm going to go and do this,"
and she said, "Well who is
this company you're leaving?
I know the company you're with.
But, why would you go and
work for a small startup?"
And she just said,
"You're absolutely crazy.
You've got security,
you got a pension..."
You know, I was like 24 years old.
And I was just thinking, you know,
with the benefit of hindsight,
I didn't take enough risks
in my early career,
but you'll get loads of people telling you
the reasons why you shouldn't do stuff,
but I think it comes back
to you in a confidence and
conviction to say, if
that's what you believe in,
then, you know, shoot for those stars
and take more risks.
- It's an interesting question
because a lot of people
get that.
They get... It's not necessarily the hate,
it's not the people who are jealous,
but it's the people who
are still close to you,
like your parents, your friends,
telling you not to go and do something,
and for a lot of people,
that holds them back,
because they really respect
and they love their mom and
they want to make them proud
and carry family traditions.
How do you, what's your
advice to people who
want to pursue a path but their
parents are blocking them?
- That's a good question. And
the other thing, at the time,
all my buddies thought I
was crazy for doing it,
because I said, you know,
I'm going to a startup,
I'll probably work sixty,
seventy, eight hours a week.
And they said, "Well we
won't see you anymore,
we won't be able to come down to the pub
for drinks and stuff."
I said, well, you know, I'll still come in
maybe, but I'll get here at
ten o'clock in the evening
instead of six o'clock.
I don't know.
But we'll find a way to keep
those relationships intact.
I think the key thing is,
and I'll directly answer
the question, the best piece
of advice I have at that age
of 24, because I went and said,
look, everybody thinks I'm crazy,
going to join a startup.
And this guy I'd worked with and knew,
as sort of a mentor,
he said to me, "Stephen,
what's the worst case
that can happen? The worst
case that can happen in a year
is the startup falls or they
fire you. And do you know what?
You can knock on the door
of the company you've left,
and they'd welcome you
back with open arms.
And actually, you would
have gained even more
experience and great life experience from
dealing with that failure
and learning from that.
You would have been a much
better entrepreneur yourself."
So, you know, when you
look at it rationally,
and you sort of divorce
yourself from the moment,
and then you say,
what could really go wrong here,
if it didn't work out,
you can always go back to where you work.
I think where you have
to deal with this, Evan,
is you have to be true to yourself.
And it kind of comes back to
the essence of where
you get your confidence,
no one here is living someone else's life.
It's not that profound,
but we only get one shot.
It's not a rehearsal.
And you got to make the most of that.
And the only thing that
just flies past is time.
When you've got the
image, and you're young,
you can work flat out, and you might not
have responsibilities.
It's a fantastic time to
really pursue your passion,
and really follow your dreams.
So, I think the folks
who are listening today,
I think it's just a, it would be a time,
if you would go home
to your mum, your dad,
even friends, and they say, kind of,
the naysayers, don't do it,
if you really believe in it,
then absolutely have the
conviction to go and do it.
You've got to live your own life.